Now returning to our look inside the black box, notice how we have multiple
operating systems running on the same shared
hardware resources. Now how is this possible?
How are the operating systems protected from one another, and who decides
who gets the resource and at what time? What we need then is an operating system
of operating systems. Something called a
virtual machine manager or hypervisor. The terminology
that you will often encounter is either VMM, which stands for virtual machine
monitor or hypervisor. And these operating systems that are running on top of
the shared hardware resources are often referred to as virtual machines, or VM
for short. We've always been using the term VM to mean virtual memory. You have
to do a, a mind shift for this lesson module, VM means virtual machine.
And each of these operating systems that
run on top of the shared hardware resource,
I'll often refer to them as either
guest operating systems or virtual machines or VM
for short. So watch out. Now, I should point out that there are two types of
hypervisors. The first type is what is called a native hypervisor or bare
metal, meaning that the hypervisor is running
on top of the bare hardware. And that's
why it's called a bare-metal hypervisor or
a native hypervisor. And all of the operating
systems that I'm showing you inside of the black box are running on top of this
hypervisor. They're called the guest operating systems because they're the guest
of the hypervisor running on the shared resource. The second
type of hypervisor, what is called the hosted hypervisor, the hosted
ones run on top of a host operating system and allows
the users to emulate the functionality of other operating systems. So the
hosted hypervisor is not running on top of the bare metal, but it is running as
an application process on top of the
host operating system. And the guest operating
systems are [UNKNOWN] clients of this hosted
hypervisor. Some examples of hosted hypervisors include
VMware, Workstation, and Virtual Box. Both of
these terminologies you may have heard of. If
you don't have access to a computer
that's running Linux operating system in this course
you're likely to be doing your course projects on a virtual box or a VMWare
workstation that's available to run on Windows
platform. For the purpose of this lesson today,
however, we will be focusing on the bare metal hypervisors. These bare
metal hypervisors interfere minimally with the
normal operation of these guest operating systems
on the shared resources in a spirit which is very similar to the extensible
operating systems that we studied earlier, like the spin and exokernel and
therefore the bare metal hypervisors, offer the best performance
for the guest operating system on the shared resource.